good morning John pretty much every
video for the last like eight years I've
been sitting here in front of my Narnia
poster and my bookshelf and there's like
a broader room in here I will I will
show it to you if you've been paying
attention you've seen some of it like
the background of project for awesome
and this is the old games with Hank set
which I don't use anymore but now I use
it from when I'm doing microscopy I sit
there and then there's like this whole
there's like a big area of room here
that I don't use much it's mostly just
to walk through and to put stuff on the
floor but one thing I've always felt is
that this is too open like I want to be
in a smaller space so this is me right
before I start to put all of these books
in boxes and I'm feeling a little bit
like emotional about this which is silly
of course but it's a space where many
amazing things have happened and I'm a
little worried about having a space
that's constructed rather than having it
be something that just sort of happen
and I don't think it's going to feel
this way but I don't want it to feel
sterile like I'm the kind of guy who
likes to see a couple of beer bottles on
the porch and I guess it's just going to
be really big change so I'm just trying
to get used to that I've of course
planned this in advance I this is
recorded several weeks ago uh so that
this can happen where I think really
hard I hope I gotta like this here it
comes
okay oh my God okay the thing that I
love the most is that I could just be in
this little corner of my office and I
can see where like all the points where
I'm gonna throw stuff beyond that but
down back in here
I can reach everything at once and I can
see everything I've got bins and bins
and bins and I got space for more bins
if I need them and I got a lot of desk
space and I got a whole wall of stuff
here and a whole wall of shelves here
this is my dream but I also have to show
you the rest of the room so let's start
out coming in coming into the room this
is what you see when you walk in to your
right is a little drum cave where Oren
and I can play the drums here we got a
whole weird set of shelves and inside
this set of shelves is a little
microscopy room where I can do my
microscopy also I can come in here and
turn on a noise machine and turn off the
lights and pretend that nothing
including myself exists I got a place
for my pizza John rug and I've also got
this whole huge wall of shelves and
honestly this is the first one it's ever
been the case for me in my life I have
too many shelves now like I don't have
enough stuff to put on my shelves here
we have my floating filing cabinet does
not currently have all my file boxes in
it but it will a thing that no one will
care about but me on top of the
microscopy shed is some storage space
and then coming on my little Nook here
we have like a little bar for running
cords and lighting we have this
beautiful set of shelves which has just
everything on this is something that I
love uh this actually right here that is
the prototype for this year's Crash
Course coin which you can only see the
front of now because the rest of it is
secret this is a painting from my mom I
think everybody's going to be very
excited about what's in here all the
Wi-Fi stuff you never have to look at it
because there's a thing that closes the
map of the realm of Narnia remains and
then people are gonna be excited about
this if you don't know what this is this
is what's called a French cleat wall
each one of these lifts off it's got a
little cleat on the back and you can pop
it anywhere on the wall and it's just a
shelf this thing can be here and I can
put this here and then turn that on and
then it's a party and then I can move
the party to a slightly different
location and it's still a party all of
this from the carpet to the floating
shelves was designed by an amazing
interior decorator named Emily Rayna who
I cannot recommend enough if you ever
want to do a weird project I encountered
her first on Tick Tock I reached out to
her I think over a year ago to start
work on this project and now it is
complete and all the carpentry and
installation and Contracting was done by
Jack Metcalf who I knew from like local
folks in Missoula I got so lucky to find
that pair of designer willing to do
really weird things and Carpenter
capable of doing really weird things
this is it I'm a little happy place I
think I'm gonna do a couple of things to
Spruce it up over the next few weeks but
man this could not have gone better John
I'll see you on Tuesday